I I love that we called each other and
you wear your black you could put
Sparkle in it I like it you're in a
cover band so I didn't know this I us to
be a okay I oh you don't do it anymore
no I should get the band back on the
road I've been busy maybe boys yeah no I
just because it's all boys you were the
only girl right yeah I started it when I
was 13 years old oh my
God I really blinged it out I used to
have I used to have like three of those
hats like and corduroy it was like my
favorite were the go-to I probably got
it from you I probably you probably
didn't I got it from five will ghost
West I got it from a movie that was long
before you but I love it I didn't know
that about you and it's interesting that
you love music and then you end up in
this role like Priscilla so what was it
like you're from Missouri right like
coming to Hollywood that was that's a
difference oh yeah that was a bit of a
culture shot yeah um yeah it was a crazy
sort of allamerican Journey it was like
we I was actually performing with the
band at like some fall festival and then
I met a guy who knew a guy who knew a
guy who lived in LA and we're like okay
let's pack the bags that was like enough
for us um but yeah was like a 25-hour
drive cross country me and my mom um you
super cool parents yeah they really
supported me yeah um stayed in some
random people Shady
places like you do what you can yes and
so that was about four years so we make
that trip multiple times a year and uh
yeah four years of nothing silence and I
think we were about to give up and then
um got my first roll like a month after
I was 18 what was it like getting and
kind of a perfect time to get your first
rooll actually to be 18 and being able
to I was a little bit older so I felt
like that was a good place to what was
it like were you in Missouri when you
got that call I was yeah I I remember I
had bad reception I couldn't hear them
like what I you know it was the last
thing I I I thought I'd lost it you know
I thought I blew the audition and then I
I went outside on my driveway and then
my parents came out and they were crying
and they were recording me on their
phone I just remember like the whole
world was spinning like and I just
called every person I could on my
contacts to let them know and that's so
exciting I remember I did the same thing
when I was on a show before you were
probably born um but I did I got I got
like so excited cuz it's like you're big
especially if you're from a small town
like nowhere near the glit and the
glamour scream on yeah a mountain top I
made it possibly like so Priscilla I
love though like I was saying you're
into music and you end up like playing
this role Priscilla who was with Elvis
so like what what was it like doing this
movie yeah it was so special because you
know growing up I was born in Tennessee
I was raised in the southern Midwest so
Elvis was like such a part of our world
you know we grew up going to Graceland
and you know I Elvis and Priscilla are
so iconic they're like American royalty
but I didn't know her side of the story
I find that interesting I know I didn't
either I know that was so exciting about
it to get to you know I think it's long
overdue to hear her side of things and
yeah and to see him from a different
Vantage Point than most people got abely
and I I think Jacob did a beautiful job
and to have someone like Sophia Copla
tell this story who's got such an
understanding of yeah you grasp of how
to tell it from the female perspective
absolutely and she does it in such
beautiful way you know her movies are
stunning so they are aesthetically so
they're like candy yeah they yeah and in
that world that like' 60s Americano so
rich and the colors fashion and yeah
that's awesome we had Jacob AI here I
fell in love with him he's great he's so
sweet so sweet little Aussie boy I was
like oh my gosh he's so sweet but one of
the things that I first of all how did
y'all Bond I'll ask that question first
just because y'all didn't know each
other before this right so you're
playing these intimate you know roles
right well sometimes you get on the set
and it's okay to meet on day one and
roll right into it but you know playing
Elvis and Priscilla we knew I knew we
had to have that connection and had to
have that trust in each other so when I
found out he got the role I was so
excited cuz I loved his work but I
didn't know how he was going to be um so
I basically emailed him and forced him
to hang out with me be friends you will
be my friend I was like do you want to
go horseback riding cuz that was
something Elvis and Priscilla loved to
do and he was so game and oh yeah oh
I've been there that's on Sunset I've
done that Hollywood yes I've been there
that's so awesome but it's kind of hard
to have a conversation though yeah I
know it was so awkward he's like behind
me riding a horse I'm like
uh so what are you close with your
family and this like group horseback
riding trip uh no but he was so great
and he was so like connected with the
the hor like he's such a Outback all
like like an yeah no I love him and one
of the things I loved about him that we
found out is he's an amazing
photographer and he took my favorite
picture he took as a view I don't know
if you've read your card yet but I was
like I hope you get a copy of it I have
to show this picture oh I want to see
this oh this is not what I've seen no no
this is beautiful I've never seen that
one it was another one that we showed
but anyway we could show it oh I've
never seen that one
either they gave us they gave us more oh
my god there he is such a great
photographer I know there was so there's
this one and you look like a first lady
like it's this one that they showed
whenever he was on it's so beautiful and
I just was like I hope you get this
picture he should send this to you this
should be your Christmas birthday I just
love that he did that because we Shot
the movie in 30 days so I sort of have
amnesia when I think back on it so it's
so fun to see those photos and it it was
such a wild Journey we all went on a
month yeah to finish the I know only a
month I just got anxiety for you and
it's already done I was like wow
[Music]
[Applause]
okay thank you guys
y'all have a great night I'm going
home